Trascrizione: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buonasera
Il mio intervento ha qualcosa a che fare
con gli interventi che ho sentito prima,
c'è qualcosa dentro che li accomuna.
Leggerò perché è una riflessione.
Non è un monologo.
È diverso.
Ho 16 anni e per una serie incredibile di coincidenze
sono arrivata nel più grande teatro d'Europa
e sono seduta al buio nella platea,
dietro al più grande regista d'Europa:
Giorgio Strehler.
Si volta e chiede al capo macchinista
di tirare delle corde di uno stangone
che dalla prima americana sorregge un leggerissimo velo bianco
che copre in parte la platea,
come una nuvola sospesa.
Con un piccolissimo movimento, la nuvola ondeggia
piena, gonfia.
Il palcoscenico è un piccolo mondo,
qualche mobile appena coperto con un lenzuolo,
un armadio sul fondo a destra, grigio,
l'armadio dei ricordi.
Proviamo "Il Giardino dei Ciliegi".
Gli attori chiacchierano tra di loro, guardo Strehler,
che è davanti a me.
È silenzioso, non dice niente, li osserva,
per un tempo lunghissimo.
Io vedo figure in controluce
che formano piccoli gruppi che poi si sciolgono,
si ricompongono, qualcuno si avvolge a una quinta.
Ora si siede su una seggiolina da bambino
Guardo muoversi la protagonista, Valentina Cortese,
luminosa, generosa, di sorrisi, di abbracci.
Poi a un certo punto c'è una figura, più pesante,
piegata dal peso degli anni,
che attraversa, piegata, lentamente la scena.
C'è solo un controluce che scontorna le figure.
Sembrano tutti muoversi in un acquario.
Da giù l'effetto è potente.
Ogni personaggio racconta un mondo.
In platea gli assistenti alla regia, i produttori,
il tecnico delle luci, Fiorenzo Carpi, il musicista,
tutti aspettano.
Strehler a un certo punto, non so perché,
si volta verso di me.
Piccola, che lo bevo con gli occhi:
"Vedi Monica", mi dice
"Non li illumino"
"Non voglio vedere la piega, il sorriso, l'espressione personale
di ognuno di loro.
Ricordati, il teatro è il racconto di un uomo
che diventa racconto di tutta l'umanità."
Guardo meglio e vedo un piccolo mondo
fatto di esili figure che sommessamente vivono
mentre il cielo, quella nuvola sopra di noi
respira.
E in quel biancore velato lentamente si dissolvono,
un mondo che scompare come il giardino,
come il loro tempo.
Sotto i miei occhi quel giorno, o era sera,
o forse notte fonda,
è nato "Il Giardino dei Ciliegi" di Strehler,
fatto di bianco, il colore dell'infanzia,
e malinconia di quel tempo che non c'è più.
Dov'è finito tutto quello che sapevo su quel testo?
La visione artistica di Strehler,
il suo sguardo in trasparenza
aveva rianimato un testo morto.
L'anima del testo liberata aveva cominciato
(respiro) a respirare, a parlare.
E parlava con una voce nuova, non prevista, originale.
E parlava anche a quella parte di me,
sempre stata solitaria, estranea,
quasi un altro mondo che avevo dentro di me, mi parlava.
Ricordo che quando vidi a Napoli il Cristo velato
ho individuato esattamente l'immagine di quello stato d'animo.
Non so se l'avete visto, è un capolavoro assoluto,
è un corpo-anima che si vela,
e fa crescere le cose al suo interno,
come se avesse dentro un altro luogo, un altro spazio.
Ed è proprio lì che aspetta il nostro talento.
Quel luogo, altro, esiste in ognuno di noi,
e aspetta, aspetta cosa? gli strumenti
gli scenari, le persone
che lo possano liberare, onorare, riconoscere.
È lui che ci fa necessari,
in questa bellissima terra.
Ma per individuarlo bisogna fare silenzio
e ascoltarlo quel richiamo
non avendo paura di farsi strada tra luoghi comuni,
preconcetti, imposizioni mediatiche;
fili che con il tempo si aggrovigliano
e diventano matasse.
C'è un termine bellissimo in fisica,
si chiama "entanglement".
È un termine che si usa in fisica quantistica
per descrivere le correlazioni che sussistono tra due particelle
che hanno interagito tra loro in un dato momento
e ora sono distanti.
Ma, hanno lasciato tracce, l'una sull'altra.
Che cosa ha creato in me
l'attaccamento a questa o a quella cosa?
a questa o a quella immagine?
a quell'oggetto, a quell'ideale,
a quel preconcetto, a quella persona?
Marionette, manovrata da esperienze passate che non ci appartengono più,
dovute a fatti, persone
di cui a volte non ricordiamo nemmeno il colore degli occhi.
Viviamo tra riproduzioni di cose,
persone, idee
di cui si è smarrita la matrice.
La replica non è l'originale,
gli si affianca, gli si avvicina,
imita solo le apparenze.
Ma ha una facile potenza di impatto, di penetrazione,
imposta dal numero che crea la sudditanza indiscussa del presente,
dove vince l'inganno generale, se è ben replicato.
Vincono i segni esteriori di una realtà
che con la sua verosimiglianza
soddisfa lo sguardo negligente sulle cose,
lo sguardo assente,
lo sguardo che non fa luce sulle cose.
Le parole stesse replicate all'infinito
perdono peso, significato, diventano suoni.
La quantità si impone sul senso.
Le nostre parole d'ordine, scriveva Brecht,
sono diventate confuse,
il nemico le ha stravolte
fino a farle diventare irriconoscibili.
Raccontava Vittorio Foa
che quando vide un'immagine dei campi di concentramento di Auschwitz
provò una grandissima pena, un senso d'orrore,
a vedere quei corpi che aspettavano dietro le reti.
Vide quella stessa immagine replicata su dei manifesti
una volta, due, tre, quattro.
Alla fine non c'era più niente di quell'orrore.
Fotografare la realtà
è replicarla senza lo sguardo sull'invisibile,
non ha lo spessore della realtà e di tutti i suoi effetti infiniti.
Ma dà l'illusione di sapere tutto.
In quell'illusione di un tutto che non ti colpisce mai,
non ti emoziona mai, non ti graffia mai
cresce l'indifferenza, a tutto.
(Applausi)
Non tutti sanno che i fatti
vengono memorizzati attraverso
il legame che si crea tra due sinapsi nel nostro cervello.
Ma non tutti sanno che per creare questo legame
c'è bisogno di un altro elemento chimico fondamentale.
È un liquido che aiuta il viaggio del neurone,
non attraverso il tunnel dei neutrini.
La trasmissione dell'informazione,
questo humus è secreto solo dalle ghiandole della fertilità,
senza calore, senza partecipazione emotiva
non si fissa niente.
Voglio rinunciare a un po' di velocità,
per dare tempo all'introspezione,
alla riflessione.
Quel tempo vuoto che permette ai fatti
come dice Keats, di trasformarsi in esperienze.
In quel luogo che lui stesso chiama il luogo del "fare anima".
Sono in una sala cinematografica a Roma,
sono andata a vedere "Il Cacciatore di Aquiloni.
Accanto a me si siedono, a film cominciato, un ragazzo e una ragazza,
si stravaccano, mangiano pop corn,
messaggiano ininterrottamente con i cellulari.
Lui fa il bullo e lei la scema.
E disturbano.
E il film non lo vedono.
"State calmi", li fulmino dopo un po'.
"State calmi e quieti", ripeto al ragazzino
che mi guarda come se fossi un alieno,
mentre la ragazzina ridacchia
accucciata scompostamente nella sua sedia, manco fosse a casa sua.
Solo: "Beh?"
Un "Beh" generico, cerca di interloquire lui, privo di vocabolario.
"Voglio vedere questo film
che tra l'altro racconta una grande storia.
Se a te non va, cambia sala e vai a vedere 'Natale a New York'".
"Capito?"
"Stai buono!" e chiudo.
Ha fatto effetto.
Sono stati zitti quel tempo che è bastato
perché l'anima del film parlasse ai due ragazzi
con un linguaggio delicato, quasi sconosciuto,
quello del sentimento.
Perché cominciassero a entrare nella storia dei due bambini.
Zitti anche nell'intervallo.
A fine film lui teneva la testa bassa, piangeva,
non si voleva fare vedere.
L'ho capito e andando via gli ho lanciato un piccolo sorriso.
Quel ragazzo, alla fine del film,
aveva fatto esperienza
del sentimento del dolore,
della sofferenza per il tradimento,
per l'abbandono, per la guerra,
per la solitudine.
In quelle due ore aveva fatto anima.
Scrive Bergman,
ci insegnano la geometria, la geografia, la vita dei pesci negli oceani.
Non ci dicono assolutamente nulla su come siamo fatti dentro.
Hai mai sentito un professore dire a un bambino:
"Ecco, questo è un sentimento."?
Se non è così,
le immagini che acquistano sempre più potenza e visibilità
ci scuotono per pochi attimi,
ferite improvvise subito sanate,
una serie di piccole cicatrici.
E per difesa, il tessuto emotivo che fa?
Si fa fibroso, spesso, forse per non sentire?
Per non sentire il senso di inadeguatezza
che la concezione del mondo sterile, indifferente
nel quale abbiamo vissuto in questi anni ci impone?
Un adattamento che ci scolla senza cancellare totalmente
la presenza di quel richiamo dalle profondità
e rende le nostre vite piatte,
al massimo bidimensionali.
È indicativo che proprio le donne che, per natura,
sono costantemente in movimento;
siano le più colpite da questa imposizione
all'omologazione.
Sciogliersi e riformarsi con le lune,
con l'adolescenza, nella maternità, nell'età.
Questo siamo noi.
E questo è possibile assecondando la nostra carne.
Così come facciamo quando lasciamo libero il pensiero
di accogliere il nuovo ogni giorno.
Ho vissuto i miei 20 anni,
i miei 30, i miei 40,
voglio vivere i 50, i 60, quello che ci sarà
in prima persona, presente, consapevole, con gli occhi aperti.
Guardando gli altri, non solo me stessa.
Non con l'attenzione centrata in ogni istante
sui miei buchi da coprire, le mie cicatrici, le mie labbra,
i miei zigomi, come sto, come appaio?
come mi vede? Io, io, io, io.
Questo placa l'assenza di un noi.
Analfabeti emotivi, assistiamo alle guerre,
all'infelicità di padri e figli costretti dalla crisi
a impedirsi a vicenda di vivere.
A bambini che muoiono di fame in terre lontane,
eppure vicinissime.
Alla nostra Italia distrutta dall'incuria,
a uomini e donne che sguazzano nella corruzione
e nell'oscenità e tutto si ferma nella retina.
Tutto è una fotografia, una verità piatta,
senza spessore e profondità e senza conseguenze.
Concentrati su noi stessi,
il mondo lo portiamo avanti per abitudine.
Parafrasando Clarissa Pinkola Estes,
quando uno spirito si piega al suo predatore
è catturato o confinato.
Invece di vivere liberamente, comincia a vivere falsamente.
La promessa ingannevole del predatore
è che assoggettandosi diventerà re o regina
mentre in realtà si programma il suo assassinio.
Quando gli esseri umani aprono la porta della loro esistenza
ed esaminano la carneficina in quei luoghi fuori mano
perlopiù scoprono l'assassinio dei loro sogni,
dei loro obiettivi, delle loro speranze più importanti.
Trovano pensieri e sentimenti e desideri
e talenti privi di vita.
C'è molto di più,
di grandemente intenso e luminoso che penetra, riempie,
permea ogni atomo dell'universo.
E accade che attraverso degli squarci della nostra coscienza
se ci lasciamo andare al cambiamento
si percepisca questa immensa forza.
Quale angelo avrà indicato la strada a Giovanna d'Arco?
Chi ha sussurrato a lei e a tanti uomini e donne
che hanno saputo guardare lontano:
"Da questa parte."
"Di qua."
Con quale forza il giovane studente ha fermato in Piazza Tienammen
i carri armati dell'esercito cinese?
Il coraggio comincia, dice Dorfman,
quando una voce si fa sentire.
Grazie.
Tutti noi descritti come una massa informe
percepiamo un pieno diverso, immateriale
che però, in alcuni momenti,
si popola di immagini, visioni, bisbiglii,
richiami, da un luogo misterioso, da un nostro se,
che teniamo distante, ma di cui abbiamo nostalgia.
Sono a Città di Castello, a poche ore dall'andata in scena,
sono in sala e guardo il palo che segna la fine di Giovanna d'Arco,
immobile e potente, sembra in attesa.
Così come in attesa sembra il silenzio
che tra poco lascerà il posto al calore e alla forza di lei.
E quel teatro ora vuoto si riempirà in ogni fessura
del suo coraggio.
Alzo gli occhi così, come a prendere misura dello spazio
seduta sulla poltrona della platea e vedo
sopra di me un affresco con un sole e una luna
ed al centro una scritta incredibile:
"Videor ut video"
"Essere visti per vedere"
"Vedere"
Non "Farmi vedere"
"Vedere", questo è il talento che ho onorato
e difeso con tutte le mie forze.
Vedere,
la forza e la grandezza che è in ogni uomo e in ogni donna
quando ascolta la propria vocazione.
Vedere la paura che è in ognuno di noi
e la vittoria sulla paura, il senso del destino
e attraverso questo sguardo immateriale, sull'invisibile
prendere coscienza nuovamente dell'aspetto spirituale
che ci rende meravigliosi.
Questa consapevolezza deve contrastare la disperazione
che viene dall'idea di vite senza senso.
L'ho sentito anche prima.
Senza futuro, perché quello è il terreno
che ci rende paurosi, fragili.
Nessuna cattedrale da costruire,
nessuna opera d'arte,
nessun talento personale che contribuisca allo sviluppo materiale,
civile, intellettuale della società.
Nessuna memoria di se, in un luogo dove ci insegnano
che di noi non ci sarà nessuna memoria
Alziamo lo sguardo, siamo circondati da opere
piccole e grandi di coloro che ci hanno preceduto.
La fine non conclude tutto,
non ferma il progresso.
La costruzione del mondo futuro non rende sterile,
inutile ogni slancio, ogni cosa naturale
caratterizzata da un principio che la spinge
alla realizzazione della propria essenza.
Tutto questo ha a che fare con una percezione
dell'aspetto spirituale dell'esistenza
che attraverso l'arte vive nel tempo.
E in questa vita che non ha più il limite della brevità,
di un'esistenza che passa,
proviamo a ritrovare il senso del divenire,
e la meta del movimento.
C'è un grande dono nella vita che non è solo felicità,
è intenerire e intenerirsi.
Rendere e rendersi teneri ai colpi subìti,
riconoscere negli altri la stessa tenerezza.
Questo è un imperativo per dirsi esseri umani.
È questo che conta, che dà un senso al nostro vivere insieme.
Mi raccontava qualcuno
che la mattina dell'attentato alle torri gemelle era a New York
era sceso per strada,
istintivamente aveva sentito l'impulso di stare con gli altri
nessuno sapeva ancora cosa fosse realmente accaduto,
ma tutti avevano la percezione
che qualcosa di molto grave li avesse colpiti,
c'era silenzio intorno,
le persone camminavano sui marciapiedi lentamente,
ma quello che lo colpì era che tutti si guardavano in faccia.
Gli occhi cercavano gli occhi di chi veniva incontro
e prima che ti superasse c'era il riconoscimento
di un identico smarrimento.
Diceva questo mio amico,
per la prima volta quella mattina ci siamo sentiti tutti vicini,
intimi, non più estranei che si sfiorano e incrociano a occhi bassi,
sconosciuti chiusi ognuno nel proprio mondo,
ma tutti dentro quel mondo, uniti nello smarrimento.
Basta alzare lo sguardo e incrociare lo sguardo di un altro
per entrare in contatto, per sentirsi parte di un quartiere,
di una città, di uno stato, del mondo.
Non è difficile.
Cittadini di un mondo che tutti noi possiamo fare più bello.
In Italia, pochi giorni fa, senza nessuna organizzazione
un migliaio di ragazzi, spontaneamente, sono arrivati a Genova.
E hanno cominciato a fare che?
A spalare. Il fango.
Spontaneamente.
Osservando l'esistenza, dice Kafka,
si partecipa alla vita, si tiene il passo con il vento.
Il vento, nuovo, bussa alle finestre proprio in queste ore.
Tra poco possiamo ricominciare a respirare.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)